[Musique]
demain il sera possible de faire le tour
de paris en voiture par le boulevard
périphérique sans en sortir la boucle
est bouclée depuis plusieurs jours déjà
une boucle de 36 kilomètres que le
premier ministre monsieur messmer
inaugurera demain matin et qu'une équipe
19,2 à tester il y a une dizaine de
jours le boulevard périphérique de paris
a bouclé sa boucle son dernier tronçon
porte d'asnières porte maillot est
terminée 35 km 500 d'autoroute en pleine
ville quatre-vingt trois ouvrages d'art
dont 9 échangeur qui permettent à chaque
file de circulation d'arriver sur
l'autre voie sans croisement ce
boulevard périphérique est une des
réalisations les plus importantes de la
france moderne elle est coûteuse 2
milliards de francs 55 millions le
kilomètre est souvent critiquée avant
son inauguration
nous avons voulu faire une expérience
avec la mise en service de ce dernier
tronçon combien de temps faudra-t-il
pour faire le tour de paris sans
rencontrer un seul feu rouge
deux cent mille automobilistes le font
chaque jour nous avons choisi une heure
de pointe 19h et une date de grands
départs vendredi 13 avril
19h17 entre la porte de saint cloud et
la porte d'orléans premier problème
notre voiture est bloquée sur la file
centrale où progressent à 10 km 19h32
les choses vont s'arranger
peu après 20h nous arriverons dans l'est
de paris mais déjà la nuit est tombée
la circulation dans le nord en direction
de l'autoroute a1 est moins dense que
dans le sud
il nous faudra néanmoins plus d'une
heure et demie pour boucler le tour de
paris cette expérience n'a aucune valeur
d'exemple elle permet néanmoins de faire
certaines constatations une notamment
ses prises de vue ont été tournées
vendredi à 17h30 le périphérique sud est
déjà encombré à côté le boulevard des
maréchaux qui ceinturent également pari
est presque vide
pourquoi parce que le boulevard
périphérique c'est la solution de
facilité
pas de feu rouge une bonne signalisation
alors on s'y entassent sans réfléchir
aux conséquences
le mal ne vient sans doute pas seulement
de l'ain la banlieue c'est développer
plus vite que prévu le périphérique est
il trop petits ou les automobilistes
trop nombreux à l'emprunter
quelle est la solution le doublement du
périphérique que peut techniquement être
envisagée mais ça ne paraît pas une très
bonne solution il est mauvais de
concentrer sur un seul tracé des débits
considérable parce qu'à ce moment là il
n'est plus possible de sortir dans la
voirie urbaine telle qu'elle existe
par conséquent les aménagements d'avenir
doivent plutôt porté sur des rocades
parallèle aux périphériques mais
et un ou deux kilomètres plus loin que
lui que faut-il faire en attendant les
embouteillages sont aussi nombreux sur
le périphérique qu'à la concorde ou sur
les grands boulevards
une autre expérience la traversée de
paris d'est en ouest 10 km 900 à
parcourir une heure et un jour favorable
la circulation 48 minutes pour traverser
paris
22 minutes pour le même parcours par le
périphérique 28 minutes par le boulevard
des maréchaux
même expérience du sud au nord même jour
16 heures de la porte d'orléans à la
porte de la chapelle 9 km 200
traversée directe de paris 42 minutes
même parcours par le périphérique
10 bis minutes boulevards des maréchaux
27 minutes pour ou contre l'utilisation
abusive du boulevard périphérique par
les automobilistes commencé en 1956 il a
aujourd'hui la silhouette de l'an 2000
souvent critiqué menacé depuis longtemps
d'asphyxié par certains il est emprunté
chaque jour par deux cent mille
véhicules
cela prouve avant tout qu'il est
indispensable à paris à la région
parisienne et aux liaisons rapides avec
la preuve
[Musique]